The Joe Rogan experience. Do you watch
sports? I watch football. That's it. Yup.
Do you worry about brain damage? Uh,
well yeah cause it's gonna ruin the NFL.
Do you look at it differently?
We away?
Do you look at it differently than you
did like before that concussion movie? Uh,
well I played high school football.
I've,
I've got hit so hard that I've
seen stars and that kind of stuff.
But I think that can happen.
I don't look at it differently.
To answer your question. No, no.
I think that it, it, you know,
they might change the helmets and
they've tried that over the years.
Do you remember it?
Like it was just leather helmets.
There was less concussions because you
would not lead with your head. Exactly.
Now you have a weapon on your head and
people have used this such and so I would
love, you know how they do throwback
uniforms? Let's see. I mean,
let's go throw back equipment.
Let's put the helmet back on.
Tick that tick tat stupid face mask off.
You really should.
But you'd have to change so much. You
have to change so much in the way people,
there's so many different factors. The
way that practice where they set up plays.
Yeah, we would have to be a new game.
I don't think it's going to happen.
I think the perception of the helmet
being safer, fuck the game up.
I really think it did well,
but you know, all right.
I used to think that a
bare knuckle boxing I like,
they should have bare knuckles in the UFC.
But then I've been watching this bare
knuckle boxing stuff and people get caught
up so bad. Now I'm thinking,
you know what? It's better
to have padded and uncles.
It's better. Yeah, it's better
for the fighters that helps.
The leather helmets were padded.
They just weren't like a hard shell.
And the Shell is what made it,
uh, you know, used it as a weapon.
So that's literally the only way you're
going to be able to stop some of this
brain damage.
And you're still not going to stop at all.
There's still colliding into each other.
They say these guys are
getting brain damage from
getting hit in the chest. Yeah,
they're getting hit in the chest and
the head snapped back and the brain
swashing around inside their skull.
Well, they're, they're changing. I think,
um,
maybe like a younger,
like little league now it's like you
can't do tackle football until a certain
age. So now that everyone's, you know,
it's all flag football til a certain age.
I think that that'll probably
happen. And Yeah. And then,
uh, the practices will be different
where we only do pads once a week.
Save it for the real game will be amazing
if the ever came up with something
that definitively fixed it, like some stem
cell treatment or something like that,
that regenerate brain tissue and bring
you back to your normal state. Right.
If they do that, then we don't have
to worry about it anymore. Right.
But until that man, oh, that's gotta
be around the corner, that's close.
I think that's a very complex question
of how to regenerate neural tissue,
brain tissue,
how to get rid of all those abscesses
and all those things you see in those
people's brains. And FCT, they developed
these like holes in their brain. Yeah.
It's serious shit. Yeah. It's,
um, while that sport though,
did you play football or no?
No, no. I wrestled in high
school. I was a little man.
It wasn't that I wrestled 134 pounds.
[inaudible] been a run of bad
fucked up fuck out of here.
There was another dude show. The fastest
guys are small and just, you know,
it was that facet runner. I was a
fast kicking and punching and stuff,
but I wasn't really that faster runner
been doing a lot of running. But um,
when I was, uh, in high
school when I was wrestling,
they were trying to tell
me to like the coach,
coach Murphy who is also
the wrestling coach,
he was also the football coach and he's
like, oh, come on, you're a sick fuck.
You should, you should play
football. Yeah. And I was like, dude,
that guy plays football. We are this
heavyweight. His name is Bobby Baker,
who's 300 pounds. He was enormous.
You're so big. I was like,
he's not squashing me
the fuck out of here.
The hardest I've ever been hit was
by a little dead and practice. Um,
probably like five, seven,
and he just, he was a,
a db and it was a practice.
I was like third string
running back and they're like,
I was just running up the gut and I
was falling into the end zone. Right.
It was over. And this case, he had
a run start like 20 yard head start.
And it was like he came up from
out of the ground and went, wow.
Didn't lock me back up. Whoa. And
that's the hardest I've ever been here.
It was by a little guy.
So you know,
think about you momentum
pito yeah, torpedo. Yeah.
With a hard helmet.
That's what he led with that helmet.
But you know how fast I go,
really good athlete can run and just think
of all that mass behind them and just
cock crash. Yeah. Yeah.
That's the way those guys get hit and
the amount of force behind them getting
hit. It's probably unlike anything in
sports other than a car accident. Right.
Other than like the white car.
Yeah.